next to the stage is the very funny very
cool
very ninja-like simply for the fact that
he's like he was over there and all
black and i couldn't see him
no come on hans kim everybody
give it up make some noise yeah
wow hey what's up guys it's good to be
called a ninja because i'm wearing black
and not because i'm
an asian i'm sure it's because of the
black clothes and not
my whole face and race um
on the way over here i saw a dude had a
mask on
normal and then he had a cough coming up
so he took his mask
off to cough into the air which uh
made me wonder how this guy has sex like
does he have sex with a condom on then
oh i'm about to come let me take it off
real quick
i almost got semen on this condom
that would have been a mess could have
ruined a perfectly good condom
it's crazy pandemic times uh because i
wear glasses
and sometimes i'll wear headphones and a
mask and my ear has to carry it all
it's like i got pandemic ear this ear is
strong man
20 20 is that you're the strong ear
we got buff ears i look back on pictures
of 2019
a pity those weak eared fools they had
no idea how to live life
they couldn't survive an apocalypse much
less two of them back to back
uh so we are in an anarchy zone trump
said it it is true
um i will sell my body for a safe
passage home
uh i will sell one of the children for a
gallon of gasoline
so so you have two gallons of gas
i'm willing to sell both of them to you
hannah lets me um
you know it's an anarchy zone please put
your
ar15s turn the safety on uh let's just
try to get through this show
you know trump says make america great
again which means he hates what we have
now so he wants to go back to the past
but if we go back to the past we're just
gonna get this again
exactly how you get this [ __ ] that you
hate so much is
what we did in the past that's like
being like i hate cakes let's go back to
the time we mix the flour with the egg
and put it in the oven
that was my favorite time that's how you
get cakes you idiot
um i think rednecks are awesome because
rednecks can survive in any wilderness
situation that you put them in
except the situation where everyone has
equal rights
that kind of [ __ ] them up you can live
with a swamp with an alligator why can't
you live in a cul-de-sac with a minority
figure it out have you tried smiling
um you know i love white people i think
white pride is a good thing
but i think a lot of people do it
incorrectly they're always into like the
nazis or the confederate flag they're
never into building a castle or yodeling
that's not white pride that's racism you
don't have to be white to be racist i
can hate the jews too
i don't but it could um i was uh
on an airplane and i saw a dude reading
a book in arabic which kind of freaked
me out
but then i saw him fold the corner of
the top of the page and put the book
away and i was like oh thank god he's
got future plans
i just got destroyed by an arab
you guys like arabs
those
no i'm just kidding they have good
kebabs and uh they drive
very fast in their taxis um
i am asian people uh say that we like to
eat dogs
which i understand can be very shocking
because in america dogs are treated like
family members
but in asia we treat our family members
like family members
instead of buying an animal we just love
our grandma
we treat everyone better in asia unless
they're a baby girl which case we throw
them in the river
but everyone else you should better i uh
i think it's funny that tanner is a
white person's name
kinda then what you're white
[ __ ] it should be like hey this
is my mexican friend tanner
it's my
[Laughter]
a lot of people in seattle are
pro-immigrants but i don't think that a
lot of people have talked to immigrants
like i have they're very annoying people
they're always like go clean your room
move out of my basement stop smoking
weed it's like okay
mom real name
goddamn mammograms um
you know i don't understand these people
who hate uh mexican people they're like
mexican people are destroying this
country which i think would be hilarious
if that was true
uh 500 years from now they're like here
lies the ruins of america
they were able to survive world war ii
and the great depression but they were
brought down by people helping them
i really [ __ ] them up they were
conquered with sponges and lawnmowers
if mexicans can destroy your country you
deserve to be destroyed
no just kidding they're very strong with
the drugs and the cartels
please don't shoot me joe gomez and chop
my head off and hang it off a bridge
um you know i love uh english language
you know people are like learn to speak
english or get out of my country but
english is a
class on a school like what if they did
that for math you know
they're like learn to find next or get
out of my country
the real language i don't understand
people who uh get mad at people who
speak broken english because that's uh
people learning to speak your language
that's your plan in action
they're not stuttering and stammering to
wrap their hood
difficult language to learn you know
these people who want everyone to speak
english are never the type of people
that want to have a conversation with a
foreigner
they're never like learn to speak
english so i can learn more about diwali
the festival of whites
i just want to be educated they just
want like lottery tickets and
a pack of cigarettes from the local
convenience store
i love arab people i'm sorry about that
it's just
don't cancel me and 9 11 was an inside
job
thank you very much